dass wir stehen hier auf dem vorplatz
zum düsseldorfer hauptbahnhof wir kommen
nicht mit der kamera auf die gleise
aber wir können das auch von hier
erzählen also es müssen sich auch
wirklich hier dramatische szenen
abgespielt haben man kann davon ausgehen
dass die mutter für sich das leben
beenden wollte
es muss eine zugfahrt gegeben haben wo
sie mit ihrem sohn noch zum hauptbahnhof
nach düsseldorf gefahren ist und hat
dann wohl nach unseren informationen den
jungen in den zug gesetzt zur oma nach
mönchengladbach und das muss man sich
mal vorstellen
wir gehen weg von der mutter sie hat
beschlossen dass sich das leben zu
nehmen und ich gehe davon aus und ich
glaube dass es auch so ist ich glaube
nicht dass sie sich nur schwer verletzen
wollte sie hatte mit der sache
abgeschlossen
jetzt hat sie überlebt weil man weil sie
gerettet wurde und jetzt gehen wir auf
den elfjährigen jungen weiß was in
diesem in dieser wohnung noch passiert
ist was der junge mitbekommen hat wer
weiß was auf der zugfahrt eventuell noch
gesprochen wurde
der junge ist elf jahre war der große
bruder hat fünf seiner geschwister
verloren hat dann auch jetzt sehr
wahrscheinlich seine mutter für längere
zeit verloren wenn es zu einem prozess
kommt und man muss sich einfach nur mal
in die lage versetzen was in einem
elfjährigen jungen vorgehen muss der
wahrscheinlich jetzt auch der wichtigste
zeuge in dieser sache wird es wäre
natürlich auch fragen laut nachdem
nachdem am nach dem jugendamt aber das
sind natürlich fragen die wir heute noch
nicht beantworten können jetzt ist es
erst mal wichtig dass dem jungen
geholfen wird dass er vernünftig in
obhut genommen wird dass die familie
zusammenhält und dass er möglichst viel
wärme und liebe erfährt und wir werden
uns weiter melden wenn es hier
neuigkeiten gibt